Julius Thomas former NFL tight end he
played with the Broncos Jags dolphins he
went to the Pro Bowl two times he's
retiring from professional football and
I'll let Julius tell you why he is
retiring he joins us now
Julius thanks for joining us where are
you right now how's it going I'm uh I'm
actually down in a Fort Lauderdale just
hanging out on campus just actually a
stepped out of class a couple of minutes
ago
wait so you're you're taking classes all
right explain to the audience you
retired from professional football and
you are going to do what yeah I am I'm
really looking forward to pursuing my
doctorate in psychology it's just really
been something that you know I feel like
it's just been calling out to me and I
understand the importance of you know
providing that that mental stability and
health for everybody I mean it's it's a
national issue for us in our country but
I think especially so in high performing
professions especially sports you're
thirty years of age and as you told the
players tribute on Friday you're gonna
focus your doctorate on investigating
the effects of contact sports on brain
trauma and neural behavioral performance
hell I can't even say it let alone study
it and you're gonna be participating in
research to identify early warning signs
of brain disease do you think you have
this do you think you are have any CTE
concussions Julius um you know that's
something that you know I'm really
looking forward you know just for myself
and investigating and seeing you know
some of my inflammatory levels but you
know we never know we're trying to
figure out you know what goes into to
creating these neural degenerative brain
disorders and you know it's just a
relatively new study so we're gonna have
to do a lot of studies myself and a lot
of people included but you know I think
we're on to the right track and we're
starting where we can what do people say
when you said you're going to retire and
pursue your doctorate I think that uh
most people are a little shocked that I
didn't decide to just you know hang out
at the house and
and enjoy being retired for a while but
I think the people that know me best I
really knew that I was looking forward
to an intellectual pursuit and I knew
that I was gonna have to find something
that you know really gave me a challenge
but also allowed me to help others you
know that's something I've really been
focused on lately can football ever be
safe well you know I mean I don't think
life is safe I think that uh we're
always at risk you know every time we do
anything every time you leave the house
every time you take part any activity
can it be safe you know it's a violent
game you know there's a lot that goes
into it but I think that there's things
that can probably be done to make it
safer and if not make it safer there's
definite things we can do to help gives
people the right understanding of their
risks and a lot of different things that
we'll probably be able to do in the
future to help those risks for being so
extreme what's the most dangerous
position in football you know I'm
probably gonna say running back I think
that you know they have to face all
those the biggest dangers I think of
football you know you got the old
linemen all the legs around their phone
around they're taking a lot more hits
than anybody else they're having to go
through the holes or didn't they're
getting abused day in and day out so I
would definitely have to say right about
what's more important
changing hitting tackling or changing
the equipment I don't know I don't
really have enough information on you
know how much of our equipment affects
or even can help you know these are guys
that are betraying their whole life to
create force and they're really good at
it so I think that changing hitting is
something that you've seen has been
focused on I think it has to continue to
have a focus but you know there may be
something and doing and changing their
equipment they can really help as well
if you knew ten years ago what you know
now would you play football absolutely
no questions no questions did you know
when these lawsuits first came out and
the settlement with the NFL did like I'm
curious what the
conversation is with family with family
and friends not teammates but you know
do they start to sit there and wonder
and ask you about how long are you gonna
play man you know you definitely have
your your family and your friends and
people that are very concerned about
your health
you know always wanted to know you know
how long you're going to do it making
sure that you know they want to see you
with quality of life afterwards yeah and
I think that everybody does that
teammates included and I think that's
really the importance of studying and
brain injuries is so that you know you
can help people know where they're at
that probably has a lot to go into the
decisions that they make moving forward
as well as you know what are those
long-term risks how is it going to
affect you you know behaviorally how's
it gonna affect your memory and your
cognition so that you're able to have
that quality of life and then having a
decision to maintain that balance for
yourself what's the hardest hit you ever
took man but I think the hardest hit I
ever took was in the playoffs I think I
was running like a slam from the slot
maybe I was outside focused on the ball
I took a big hit I think I was one of
those plays where I think those one of
my only fumbles in the game so that was
a that was a big one
who hit you I want to say was Donald
Butler but I can't be sure you can't be
sure cuz you don't remember or know I
think that a lot to do to go back and
watch the tape hey good luck with this
you got a long life ahead of you and
hopefully you're gonna be able to help a
lot of people with this decision Julius
so we appreciate your time and good luck
and so Julius Thomas for Minnifield
signing with the Broncos Jags Dolphins
went to two Pro Bowls and uh thirty
years of age oh good for him for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience Channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
you
[Music]